building a successful career means
adapting to a rapidly changing job
market the European Social Fund helps
Europeans of all ages and abilities
upgrade their skills and acquire new
ones rescaling and upskilling
means workers can enjoy a stable career
and business can count on a qualified
workforce but some people are
disadvantaged on the job market
perhaps they're older disabled or from
an ethnic minority young people are also
finding it particularly difficult to get
work especially if they have no
qualifications ESF funded projects
provide specific training counseling and
other support to these groups to level
the playing field but they also address
the needs of other job seekers and
workers to ensure as many people as
possible have a fair chance on the job
market lifelong learning is at the heart
of the services offered through the ESF
it gives people with our qualifications
or those who want to change direction
the chance to do so by removing the
barriers to a new career
all this help is delivered locally by
organizations who know their region and
its people as we move towards a greener
digital entrepreneur driven economy with
an ageing workforce the European Social
Fund is giving people across Europe the
means to find work change career or work
longer the European Social Fund
investing in people